I've always heard that imitation is the
sincerest form of flattery so I'm very
flattered now to introduce a young man
who has done his best to dress like I do
talk like I do and look like I do ladies
and gentlemen mr. Rock Hudson
well we could be twins so much for
science fiction yeah I have the envelope
please
I just want to have it in my hand I'm so
excited I'm afraid of forget to ask for
it after I read the nominees
congratulations for those five talented
ladies nominated for Best Performance by
an actress Doris Day pillow toy Audrey
Hepburn the nuns story Katharine Hepburn
suddenly last summer
Simone's senior a room at the top and
Elizabeth Taylor for suddenly last
summer
the Monsignor a rover the car
you
oh I thank you I thank you so much I
wanted to be very dignified and all that
didn't I can't you can't imagine what it
is for for me being French you can't
imagine and I want to thank Jimmy wolf
and Jack Gleeson and Laurence Harvey
because it looks a little corny to say
that but you know that without them I
wouldn't have never been here tonight
thank you so much